We Begin this NewsHour in synagogue
where opposition leader Usman sonko has
been acquitted of rape charges however a
court has sentenced him to two years in
prison for corrupting youth songkoke was
accused of raping a woman in 2021 his
detention has led to weeks of violent
protests and widespread unrest
let's go live now to Nicholas hark in
Dhaka and Nicholas he's been acquitted
but he could still face prison time can
you just run us through the charges and
what happened in court
well essentially he has been the rape
charges have been or he's acquitted from
the rape charges as you explained but he
will still spend time in prison he's
likely to spend tonight in prison
because the judge after the evidence
that was brought to court last week by
the accuser ajisar
um convicted Usman sonko of conspiring
conspiracy of a minor because as you saw
the the person that has has accused
um Usman sankov rape was under the age
of 21 when the when the events took
place now as the conviction was read out
there was utter column on the streets of
the Capitol but look at it now I'm on
one of the main Avenues behind me all
the way down this Avenue is where Usman
Sanko lives and I'm just going to rotate
around you can see the amount of
security forces and police around and at
the very end of this road is where the
courthouse and the jail is we've been
hearing loud bangs tear gas throughout
these roads
adjacent to this road and in the next
couple of hours we expect Usman Sanko to
be picked up from his home and brought
to jail Tom
Nick I guess there's a tension there
especially around security what is the
fear uh especially with the supporters
uh when or if that does happen
but we are in one of the strongholds of
Usman sunk over the neighborhood of the
Medina and I just want you to see what's
happening around me there's there's
there's people in the neighborhoods
waiting and police in heavy riot gear
and you can see there's been rocks being
thrown around there's clashes happening
at sporadic moments it's not just here
in this neighborhood in the Medina but
even further out you can see in the
distance billowing in the clouds
um tear gas has been thrown so there's
clashes around they don't want to see
Usman sonko in jail they say that the
conviction was politically motivated
that Usman the the charges are false
that the the woman that accuses him of
rape was paid by the government they see
this as they see that the justice system
as being corrupt now makisal the
president and the government has
explicitly said that they their role is
to maintain Law and Order and this is a
criminal matter between two private
citizens but for many here it isn't it's
about politics it's about the upcoming
presidential elections of February 2024.
Tom thank you so much for that update
that's Nicholas for us in Dakar
well let's bring in Adama gay he is a
Senegalese author and journalist he is
also former director of information at
ecowas he joins us from Dusseldorf in
Germany thank you very much for being on
this NewsHour I guess first and foremost
what is your reaction to these verdicts
this is very sad it's a very sad day for
senegales democracy synagogue was not
known for dirty politics but that is
what we are witnessing now and this may
uh ushering a lot of tensions as we move
towards the 2024 presidential elections
now we are confronted with really a very
serious crisis political crisis and the
government and the opposition are at
odds which is what they've been calling
for political dialogue yesterday the
president of Senegal opened a political
dialogue for people to find a peaceful
solution to the challenges of the
country and the opposition under the
forces of 24 decided to call a dialogue
for the people but ultimately what we
see is a confrontation it is not good it
doesn't signal a good thing for Senegal
democracy what are the implications here
and what are you expecting uh from sonko
supporters today in in the days ahead
we are going into a really awesome arm
uh wrestling uh between the opposition
the youth and the government the
government is adamant about maintaining
law and order it will try to abide by
the decision made by the justice and
this is clearly a decision that is
somehow masterminded and abducted by the
government because the Justice in
Senegal is clearly controlled by the
executive hundreds of people have been
arrested and are under jail terms in
Senegal and on the other hand we have
the people in the opposition and Mr
sonko and his followers who had refused
the dialogue called for by Marcus are we
trying to find a way of exiting
peacefully from Power people expect him
to be person because a lot of
wrongdoings under his leadership on the
other hand the opposition now and Mr
sonko in particularly find himself in a
position where he may be blackmailed
into going into dialogue into accepting
what the president of Senegal wants but
The Last Resort may be unfortunately for
Senegal to witness what never has
happened in the country namely an
Arbitrage by the military because the
more we see the political forces
fighting one another creating an
economic situation that is not going
well you may run the risk of having a
third Force the military namely coming
out and saying enough is enough we must
stop this because Senegal should not go
down the drain like many western African
countries that have been experiencing a
military coup and the likes I mean so do
you really think there is a risk now a
real risk of a military coup in Senegal
look openly people are calling for it
unfortunately Senegal was known to be
the really the uh leader in terms of
democratic process freedom of opinion of
freedom of expression and the
multi-party political system we have had
that even before the independence of the
country in 1960 and in 1974 after a
period of a single party rule like many
African countries we have had
multi-party system military party
election and we have had two peaceful
Democratic transitions was seen as a
beacon of democracy across the world
when it comes to Africa that's something
that is foregone it's a spent force and
the risk is indeed because the military
forces have been asked to remain in the
Barack mainly because there was an
agreement that the politics would be
done peacefully in terms of managing the
economy in terms of providing good
governance and rule of law unfortunately
that is no longer the case the military
forces are no longer under the cut of
the civilians to remain into the
barracks okay thank you so much that is
Adam okay for us Senegalese author and
journalist thank you